Hey guys, check this out. I just got some super exciting news this morning.
12 years ago, I sold my airplane to a guy in Canada,
and he just sent me a message saying he's down here visiting in the United States, and he want's to take me for a ride.
So that's what we're doing.
How you doing George
Thanks man, it's good to see ya. How have you been?
but I gotta tell you man there's
something about being back at a small
airport this is really a nostalgic you
know the weirdest feeling right now
George is like I didn't even leave it
this is Cessna 120 it's a
taildragger it's got the tail wheel in
the back and i sold it to this guy,
George, 12 years ago and he's back in
town and asked me if I like to go for a
ride so I said yes and we're going to go
up and play with the mountains and
clouds today we're taking you along
I almost feel like I just jump in right
now and pick up exactly where I left off with it.
the main reason I bought this airplane
almost 15 years ago is because
ironically it was cheaper to buy my own
airplane than it was to rent it from a
school and build at the same amount of
flight time
so rather than going to a college or
university and paying thousands of
dollars in tuition
i bought my own airplane taught myself
how to fly, challenged the exams and
came up with all the same certifications
and ratings that I would have had
through a university but the difference
was I now had an airplane that i could
sell make my money back with put me in
the unique position of being one of the
few airline pilots who had no student
loans
now these little hinge plates here move
up and down those are called ailerons
and that's what actually turns the
airplane from side to side
what's unique about the Cessna 120
is it doesn't have any flaps like
most typical airplanes do in fact any
other airplane that we look at around
here has flaps. flaps increase the drag
which slows you down but it also allows
you to fly slower before you fall out of
the sky and makes a little bit easier to
land
so in addition to being a taildragger
having no flaps added another elemental
challenge to coming in and making a
perfect landing after a thousand hours
of flying this baby I felt like we were
connected
all right check it out guys, fuel guy is
here
Great Job.
Luminary  traffic Charlie Foxtrot Juliet Yankee India, We're taking position runway 35 then
we'll be departing  to the South for
aerial maneuvering and over Mano Lake
alright, fingers crossed those cameras stay on.
Logan area traffic Juliet Yankee India is over
Mano Lake only 7500 feet and below maneuvering.
Here we go!
Ha ha ha, Like you've never been away. That's right.
yeah, Nice shot.
Sweet!
Coke Zero. We're taking this thing to zero gravity
and here's how it works
we go on and we go down
nice landing in the back there.
Feel sick yet? Nope. I do.
So Cool.
My stomach is in knots right now.
Ha ha ha ha.
very nice!
We did it, We did it.
Oh man, it's a good thing that this camera has stabilization
because that was so awesome i'm shaking
this has been such an exciting day we
did some really cool hammerhead stalls
and then we did some stalls and spins
and most of the battery went dead on one of
my GoPro so i just got my fingers
crossed that we got that footage after
all and what's really cool is I resigned
from the airline's a couple of months
ago and I was just starting to get the
itch to go flying again and then this
guy messaged me out of the blue to go
flying in my old airplane which has been
12 years since I've seen this thing guys
this is really special experience for me
and so glad you could be here and be a
part of it and see what we saw it was a
lot of fun and a little bit rusty on my
takeoffs and landings but we made it in
the end so big thanks to this guy George
thank you. You're welcome
making the trek down. Like you've never been away. Thanks for joining us in this video
and I'll see in the next adventure
talk to you then